hey guys i'm off the grid for august but
brian stelter is still an unlikable
potato
that last segment that that that i just
had to listen to of all of the people
saying the same old stuff also you're
incredibly repetitive it's
week after week
you know you are why one of the reasons
people can't stand the media sorry
you're cracking me up it's your fault
it's my
so
what should i do differently michael
don't talk so much listen more that last
segment that that that i just had to
listen to of all the people saying the
same old stuff also you're incredibly
repetitive it's
week after week i mean you're the flip
side of of of donald trump um you know
fake news and you say virtuous news
you know i they're they're not we just
figure out what is real i mean you've
all spoken extensively about fox news
being a purveyor of uh disinformation uh
but cnn is right up there with them they
push the russian collusion hoax they
push the justice millet hoax they
smeared justice kavanaugh as a rapist
and they also smeared nick salmon as a
white supremacist all the mistakes of
the mainstream media and cnn in
particular seem to magically all go in
one direction are we expected to believe
that this is all just some sort of
random coincidence or is there something
else behind it i think you're describing
a different channel than the one that i
watch uh but i understand that that is a
popular right-wing narrative about cnn
all these networks all these news
outlets have to defend democracy
and when they screw up admit it so in
what ways has the world gone bad when
we're not allowed to acknowledge that
rioting is rioting and it is bad and
that silence is not violence but
violence is violence the world has gone
mad you say we're not allowed we're not
able who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they people let
work at networks frankly like the one
i'm speaking on right now who try and
claim that you know it was it was racist
to investigate the lab league theory
mostly peaceful
protests
yeah
laugh there um
humpty dumpty
we all know you're not reliable you are
nothing but a student
we'll let you go there donald if
anything that's happening at cnn
and anybody who buys your book
it's really just one of those things
that is dividing our nation
and i don't believe in dividing our
nation it hurts our great nation
and so
cnn is really the enemy of the truth and
that's my opinion narrative is i want to
show all kinds of opinions
which sounds great but not all opinions
are created equal you think about major
newsrooms like cnn that have health
departments and deaths and operations
that work hard on verified information
october 19. and then you have talk show
stars like joe rogan who just swing it
who make it up as they go along if brian
delter doesn't like you
that doesn't mean anything
why does he sit like this
because you ever notice he sits like
this and because figures like rogan are
trusted by people that don't trust real
news rooms we have attention a problem
that's much bigger than spotify much
bigger than any single platform kate but
that's what there's a heart of this
right